dear ministers the mayor honorable
members of parliament ladies and
gentlemen
just last year I was in narva announcing
the first award decision by the European
Union's just transition fund and today
we already celebrate the groundbreaking
of that project
Neo performance materials a Canadian
company is constructing a rare earth
refinery right here
this is the first large-scale Refinery
outside Asia it is a leap for Estonia
and a stride for Europe
the rare earth magnets that will be
produced here are indispensable to
growth and innovation in sectors like
Electric Mobility wind energy and
microelectronics
they promise lighter batteries
less consumption of critical materials
and higher Energy Efficiency
to Guarantee Supply
we are co-developing this facility with
a rare earth mine in Greenland
and this is another first
it is Europe's first mind to magnet
supply chain
while this bolsters European resilience
and security of supply
it primarily benefits local people
the economy of the iraviro region
used to rely heavily on Shale oil one of
the most dirty fossil fuels in the world
the new magnet facility with the help of
the just transition fund
will create up to 1 000 new well-paid
green jobs
managers at Neo performance materials
informed me that with their worldwide
experience
they had never seen such a fast issuance
of permits as for this facility and this
is Europe at its best
with the European the national and the
local institutions all equally on board
with fast and decisive action
with a Clear Vision for the future
the union of the future is being born
right here in narva
today all of Europe looks at you with
pride and hope thank you very much